it's interesting because women want to
be modern when it benefits them but
traditional when it doesn't I'm sorry
but why is this girl worth millions and
millions of dollars complaining about
splitting the bill I I mean you know you
wanted to be modern which is fine no
hate but don't complain about the
outcomes later and these guys are
probably thinking this girl's worth I
don't know what she's worth it's but I
would guess upwards of 10 million um
especially what they were paying for Tik
Tok brand deals back in the DI guys who
was stup it was crazy these people were
making so much money I actually I met a
bunch of the top like ticktockers back
then oh my God it it was so crazy I met
the demilios back in the day which is
like another top Tik Tock family and it
it was just briefly but it was so crazy
to me to see these like 18-year-old kids
you know driving sports cars having
private drivers going out to these super
expensive me very in very cool actually